MATTHEW SOLDO: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to my talk about
buildpacks on Google Cloud.
My name is Matt Soldo.
I am a product manager at Google
focusing on our serverless
compute platforms, Cloud
Run, App Engine, and Cloud
Functions.
And for the past
few months, I've
been working on bringing Google
Cloud's buildpacks to market.
And I'm really excited about
talking to you about them
today.
So what we'll be covering
in this talk-- first of all,
we'll go over what
buildpacks are.
We'll talk about why you
might want to use buildpacks.
And finally, we'll look
at buildpack support
on Google Cloud, how to use
buildpacks on Google Cloud,
and we'll do a nice demo tying
a few of our products together
using buildpacks.
So just in case you don't
want to sit through the entire
presentation, let's do a tl;dr.
So buildpacks create containers
without using a dockerfile.
You just give the
buildpack your source code,
and the buildpack detects
what language you're using
and creates a runnable container
that you can run locally
with Docker, or we could run
on the Kubernetes platform,
or anywhere else.
So let's just take a
look at that in action
on my laptop right now.
OK, so to use buildpacks,
we used the pack command.
That is the reference
implementation
of a buildpack platform.
And you can see the available
commands on pack here.
And we're just going to use
the most basic one, which
is pack build.
By default, it builds
the current directory.
And we're in the--
you can see-- this
java-maven directory here.
And you just need to provide
the name of the container image
that you're creating.
And we'll call this
hello-buildpacker.
And so you can see it went
through a detection phase
where it found a few buildpacks,
a Java runtime, Java-Maven and
Java entry point.
It did some analysis.
And it is now building
this application.
You can see it's using the
Google Java runtime buildpack
and using Java 11.
That's specified by our
definition, the Google
buildpacks definition, of what
to do when it finds a Java app.
And it is now
finishing up its build.
And it has successfully
done and created
this hello-buildpacker image.
So now I can just run that.
And we'll bind it
to port 80 so we
can load it in our web browser.
This is a server that
I have up in GCE.
And that was hello-buildpacker.
And it runs.
And there we go.
It's started.
And now we go over
to our web browser.
This is the address
of my server.
It wasn't working before.
But if I do a reload--
boom, hello,
buildpacker-- it works.
And so you can see, in
just a couple of seconds,
we built a Java app and got it
running in a Docker container.
And that is a quick
demo of buidlpacks.
So that was
buildpacks in action.
Now buildpacks allow
you to take advantage
of the benefits of
containers without needing
to understand them.
So you can isolate your code.
You can create
microservices architectures.
You can run on orchestration
platforms like Kubernetes
without needing to write
dockerfiles or understand
the inner workings of Docker--
so super cool.
Now recently, Google
Cloud released a set
of open source buildpacks.
You can find them on
GitHub at the address
that you see in this screenshot,
googlecloudplatform/buildpacks.
And these cover a bunch of
the most popular languages--
Go, JavaScript, Java, PHP,
Python, .NET, and Ruby.
And they are designed to create
secure container images, which
can run on any of the runtimes
from Google Cloud such as Cloud
Run, GKE, or Anthos.
And of course, because
they're open source,
you're able to fork them and
use them however you'd like.
Now even though
they're relatively new,
these buildpacks have powered
over 10 million builds
in production.
And that's because they started
off as an implementation detail
for App Engine, and
Google Cloud Functions.
And they've been powering all of
the source builds on those two
products for a while now.
So we're pretty confident
in their robustness.
And you can use them
confidently too in production.
But in addition to App
Engine Cloud Functions,
Google Cloud buildpacks
are available on many
of our products.
There's support for them in
Cloud Build, Cloud Run, Cloud
Shell, Cloud Code and Skaffold.
And we'll dive into the
specifics of that later on.
So that was the overview.
Let's dive in.
What are buildpacks, exactly?
They are a CNCF sandbox project.
Those are newer projects in
the cloud-native project.
And you could find
them at buildpacks.io.
There are several
large companies
contributing to the project
in addition to Google.
Pivotal Cloud Foundry is a
major backer, as is Salesforce,
via the Heroku division.
And like we said before,
buildpacks take your source
code, and they
create a container.
But there's a little
more to them than this.
And let's take a look at that.
Buildpacks actually
run in a container
themselves called a builder.
So here you can see, in
a little more detail,
that a container called the
builder runs the buildpacks.
And you can see there's actually
two scripts that they run.
The first one is
a detect script.
And that detects what
language your code is.
And the detection, it's
actually not rocket science.
It's an ordered list of tests.
And the first test that
comes back positive
is declared the language.
So these tests can
be very simple, like,
is there a packages.json?
And if that's true, then it's
a JavaScript application.
And you can, of
course, override those.
But you'll find that they're--
they usually work just fine.
And then after the
detection script happens,
a build step happens that
actually does the building.
So the builder, it's,
itself, an OCI image.
It contains all of the
buildpacks, and groups,
and binaries needed
to do the building.
And it runs on a platform.
And that could be as simple
as the pack CLI command
that you saw in the demo, or
something like Cloud Build
or Tekton.
And that actually
runs the image.
And you can see here
a little CLI snapshot.
The pack command, if you
invoke suggest builders,
it'll show you some of the
builders that are known to it.
And Google is one of those.
This is also showing
Paketo, which
are the-- that's the branding
of the buildpakcs from Pivotal
that were released recently.
They're also very good.
And just to add
another layer, there's
also a thing called
a buildpack group.
buildpacks themselves are
very small units of execution.
They can be designed
to do just one thing,
like run an NPM install,
just installing dependencies.
And a buildpack group is
a collection of those.
And that lets you reuse
smaller bits of code
like doing a dependency
install, and use
those across different
buildpack groups.
So when most people
say buildpack,
they're actually talking
about the buildpack
group that does the full build.
But it depends how the
buildpacks are actually
designed.
Finally, there is another
piece of the buildpack
called the stack.
And this is the base
image, or base layer,
that your application
code is put on top of.
Here we show an
Ubuntu, stack, which
is what Google Cloud's
buildpacks use.
And they can contain
some system libraries
on top of that base layer.
And then your application
code and dependencies
get put at the top
of that layer stack.
Buildpacks cannot do an apt-get
to install dependencies.
So those need to be
part of the stack.
And we have designed the
stacks for the Cloud buildpacks
to contain the most common
things that you likely need.
So you shouldn't have to
redefine that if you're
using them yourself.
So stringing all of that
together, we can see,
here, a flow diagram
where the source code gets
taken into the builder image.
The buildpacks and
buildpack groups run on it.
They run the detect
script to figure out
which language it is.
They run the build script.
They install all of your
dependencies, your source code,
whether it's compiled,
or it just, direct,
goes on top of there.
And that gets layered
on top of the stack.
And then that
layer cake that you
see on the right, the
green and the gray,
that forms the complete
container image, which you
can then run wherever you like.
So that's pretty detailed look
into how the buildpack works.
So why would you actually
want to use these things?
Well, for starters,
a recent study
found that 44% of
containers in the wild
had known vulnerabilities
for which patches existed.
This just shows that
writing your own dockerfile
can actually be quite
fraught with errors
unless you're an
expert, or maybe
have a platform team that
provides dockerfiles for you.
So using buildpacks lets
you circumvent that danger,
assuming the buildpacks are
designed with security in mind.
Now Google Cloud
buildpacks are just that.
They've been security audited.
And they're constantly updated,
making sure that they will not
produce vulnerabilities.
Or certainly, at the
bottom layer of the stack,
the base layer doesn't
have any security issues
that we're aware of.
The containers are built
according to our container best
practices--
call that the Google way--
as much as we can
via buildpacks.
And all these things let
you-- like container novices--
deploy to container
platforms like Kubernetes
without needing to write
their own dockerfiles.
And even if your organization
has adopted Docker,
maybe that adoption
is not even, and there
are some teams that
haven't yet adopted it,
but they could take advantage
of centralized platforms
for running their code.
Another use for buildpacks, even
if you do know Docker really
well, is if you just need to
do a quick and easy build.
Maybe you're checking
out an open source
project or some code
that you don't expect
to be using long-term,
and you don't
want to write a dockerfile
from scratch for it.
So just use a buildpack, build
it, try it out, and then, boom,
you're done.
Some specific Google Cloud
use cases for buildpacks--
because we're using
buildpacks to power
the builds on App Engine
or Cloud Functions,
if you want to migrate
away from those platforms
to one of our others,
like Cloud Run or GKE,
you could take those App Engine
and Cloud Function buildpacks,
you could continue to run
them against your source code,
and have the same build process
happening on your new platform.
And as you know, when
you're migrating,
keeping as many things
constant as possible
is very, very helpful to
minimize the disruption
from that migration.
Finally, another reason
to use buildpacks
is because they are so
well-integrated into so
many parts of Google
Cloud, like Cloud Build,
that you can reuse the
knowledge and those tools
across many parts of
your cloud platform.
So now let's take
a look at support
for buildpacks on Google Cloud.
First of all, we already
went over the open source
buildpacks.
You are free to fork those.
Modify them however you'd like.
It's quite easy to do.
And in the README,
you'll find documentation
on how to do that.
Cloud Build, which is
our builder as a service,
now has native support
for buildpacks.
So if you have source
code and want it built,
instead of running
buildpacks locally,
you can just push
that to Cloud Build,
and it will build it for you.
At the moment, that
support is CLI only.
But support in the console
will be coming soon.
Called Run, our next-generation
serverless platform,
supports direct source
deployments with buildpacks.
So you can just do a Cloud Run
deploy, put your source code,
and it will build and
deploy that all in one step.
You can also set up
continuous integration
with both Cloud
Build and Cloud Run,
where, every time you update
your source repository,
it will do a fresh build
of that source using
buildplaques-- buildpacks--
and deploy to Cloud Run.
Cloud Shell, which you can
access through the Cloud
Console, already has
the buildpack tool pack
pre-installed.
So you don't need to do that
if you are using our shell.
Like we talked about already,
App Engine and Cloud Functions
both are building with
buildpacks already.
And finally, Cloud Code lets
you deploy to Cloud Run or GKE
using buildpacks as
the build mechanism.
And it actually does that
via Skaffold, which also now
has native support
for buildpacks--
so a really broad
swath of support
for buildpacks
across Cloud, which
is really pretty exciting.
And now let's take a
look at that in action.
And I will show you a soup to
nuts built in deployment using
buildpacks on Google Cloud.
Let's take a look at how to use
buildpacks with Google Cloud.
So I'm back at my terminal.
And I have a pretty
simple Go app right here--
little different from the one
we were looking at before.
And if we just take a look
at the main HTML file,
you can see it's a
pretty boilerplate app.
And all it does once you get
past all that CSS is just
pulls some environment
variables from the request,
and says hello to you,
and displays those.
So let's build it.
But let's start by
assuming we actually
haven't installed
the pack command,
and just do the entire
build in the cloud.
So I'm going to use the
gcloud builds submit.
And I'm just going to
give it the pack flag
to tell it to build
this with a buildpack.
And then I'm going to
pass along the name
of the image and the full
Container Registry address
that I want to use.
So I'm just going to
call this one run.
So we do that.
And we can see it is
creating a tar ball
and uploading my app into Google
Cloud, into a storage bucket.
And then it is going to
initiate that buildpack.
And you can see, right here,
it is pulling down the builder.
These are the Docker
layers being pulled down.
And it's already cached, so
it should be pretty fast.
And so now it's running
the detection phase
of the buildpack.
That's where it decides
what language it is.
And it should show us
that-- yep-- it is using Go.
And then it does the build.
It's going to compile my
Go code using Go 1.14.
And it is doing that now.
Looks like it just finished.
And now it's going to create
my final Docker image,
putting my application
code on top of the stack.
So it's doing that.
And it looks like it is now
putting the completed image
into my Container Registry.
And that is all done.
So now that we have a
built container image,
let's deploy it.
So to deploy it, I'm
going to use Cloud Run.
That is Google's next-generation
serverless container engine.
And I'm just going to tell it
to deploy a new service to Cloud
Run, and using that
image that we just
created from Cloud Build.
So I fire this up.
And it's going to ask
me a few questions.
I'm going to choose our fully
managed Cloud Run platform.
You can, of course, also
use Cloud Run for Anthos
if you have installed that on
top of your Anthos cluster.
I haven't, so I'm
just going to choose
the fully managed option.
And I'm going to call this
my demo-run-for-screencast
service.
That should be unique.
And I'll choose the region.
Let's go US Central.
And allow unauthenticated-- just
to make this more interesting,
let's just make this
a private service
that you need to be
authenticated to use.
So I'm doing that.
And now it is
deploying the service.
And Cloud Run services
had revisions.
This will be the first revision.
And now its routing
traffic to it.
So we're all done.
And it gives me this
URL right here, which I
can use to access the service.
And I am going to hit that up.
I'm just going to use the
curl command right here so we
stay right in the terminal.
And here's my command.
I'm curling that same URL.
And you can see I'm adding a
header with an authorization
field.
And then I'm going to call
the gcloud command again
to give it my identity token.
So I do that.
And it's firing it up.
And, boom, we get a
bunch of HTML back
that is that container.
You can see, if I
do that same thing
but don't pass the
authorization token,
then I get a forbidden error.
Because I haven't
authenticated properly.
So there you just saw us
building some application code
using our service, Cloud Build,
with its brand-new native
buildpack integration.
And then it stored that
in the Container Registry.
And then we created
a brand new Cloud Run
service that was protected
via authentication.
And that all took
just a couple minutes.
And that is one of
the easiest ways
I know to build a new service
and deploy it to the cloud
securely.
Thanks very much.
So that was buildpacks in
action on Google Cloud.
So in this talk, we have
explained what buildpacks are,
why you want to
use them, and how
to use them on Google Cloud.
I hope you enjoyed
it, and I hope
you'll try buildpacks out soon.
Thanks very much,
and have a great day.